le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais l'île de la
réunion et bien arrosé les pluies sont
régulières parfois abondantes et c'est
une bonne chose pour l'agriculture
locale
mais le relief de l'île favorise les
microclimats et la répartition des
pluies est très différente d'un endroit
à un autre
contrairement à l'est il pleut beaucoup
moins dans le sud et l'ouest
les agriculteurs du sud sont sanctionnés
par des sécheresses passagère causant
des pertes et pouvant même aller jusqu'à
la faillite de jeunes agriculteurs
n'ayant pas encore assez de trésorerie
pour tenir le coup alors quelles sont
les solutions pour un approvisionnement
en eau équilibré pour tous on en parle
maintenant d'un lien social
jean michel est un jeune agriculteur
maraîcher à saint louis
quand on est agriculteur on laisse sept
jours sur sept
un travail éprouvant qui nécessite une
véritable passion
c'est le cas de jean michel il aime ce
qu'il fait malheureusement ces dernières
années le sud de l'île a subi des
périodes de sécheresse régulière un
manque d'eau qui complique terriblement
le travail et met en danger son activité
sans eau pas de culture possible et sans
soutien
jean-michel ne pourrait même plus
exercer aujourd'hui si vraiment c'est
une coupure s'est pas trop trop trop
grave nous on sera coupée une journée
pas plus mais sinon si c'est pas pour
cilaos le bras de la paix n'y a pas
d'eau bien on est comme tout le monde on
a des pompages sur le plateau du goal
qui permet justement quand le bresse la
hausse le bras de la plaine et yappa dos
est saturé un bout on a la négation je
pense qu'on a deux ou trois dieux
station de pompage dans dans les bacs
qui nous aide nous rendre à maresché
l'eau tous les jours jean michel reçoit
un soutien technique pendant les
périodes de crise
il a bénéficié des pour acheminer l'eau
jusqu'à son exploitation est installé un
système de goutte-à-goutte
les normes sont très exigeantes et sans
aide son système d'irrigation n'aurait
pas pu être achevée car trop coûteux
pour lui sans les haines
on ne peut pas s'en sortir comme je vous
dis si on est installé depuis longtemps
on a la trieuse aurait depuis longtemps
on peut sentir dès qu on est jeune c'est
très difficile sans le conseil général
aujourd'hui c'est très très difficile
pour remédier aux problèmes récurrents
que rencontre jean-michel et l'ensemble
des agriculteurs du sud depuis plusieurs
années le département a lancé un gros
chantier pour créer une interconnexion
entre le bras de la plaine et celui de
cilaos améliorer l'acheminement de l'eau
dans toutes les régions de l'île un
engagement du conseil général depuis des
décennies des travaux lourds et coûteux
mais nécessaire pour que la population
réunionnaise sans exception puissent
recevoir son eau toute l'année sans
coupure sans même y penser
les besoins sont partout qu'on soit
particuliers agriculteurs organismes
privés ou publics
l'eau c'est la vie le conseil général de
la réunion depuis plus de 40 ans
maintenant même un chantier énorme
concernant l'aménagement hydraulique de
l'île de la réunion est actuellement
c'est vrai que la micro région sud qui a
connu il ya quelques mois beaucoup de
contraintes de sécheresse nous a fait
encore plus active et le processus de
mise en oeuvre de la de l'interconnexion
rural la paix n'est pas de chalosse dans
un premier temps en deux phases et
ensuite il y aura aussi une
interconnexion entre le projet îlot et
brian rafalski rampant sera encore plus
les besoins en eau de ce secteur que ce
soit pour les besoins grippol dans un
premier temps sur les périmètres
irrigués également sur les besoins des
usagers domestiques et des entreprises
il faut savoir que pour pouvoir
alimenter l'ensemble du cgd réunion le
conseil général tous les ans sur à peu
près 180 millions d'euros utilise à peu
près plus d'un tir de ces sommes pour
l'aménagement hydraulique de l'eau ici à
l'est de la rue
l'eau est un facteur primordial de
l'économie à la réunion et dans les
années à venir
l'enjeu de l'eau sa quantité sa qualité
seront des thèmes majeurs
le conseil général investit depuis des
années dans des infrastructures
permettant d'équilibrer les ressources
partout dans l'île objectif permettre à
tous les réunionnais d'est en ouest du
nord au sud de ne jamais manquer de cet
élément essentiel de leur quotidien
l'eau
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais